so of course i'm going to ask you uh how
is the shoot going for guardians 3 and
what can you tease fans
um
it's going great you know chuck woody
who plays mern in peacemaker is one of
the main characters in the movie and
people are freaking out over how good
this guy is like literally freaking out
um
and so i think that uh i'm really happy
i gave a bunch of scenes to
uh marvel at the beginning of uh
at the beginning right before christmas
break and uh and uh and kevin went
you know they're all really
really really stoked but also it's not
to be the movie people it's it's
different than what people are going to
expect but it's uh it's it's it's a hard
road but i'm really happy with it so far
are you filming have you started filming
the holiday special yet or is that still
upcoming in the shoot it's still
upcoming in the shoot uh we were
supposed to shoot in um
uh one day in la uh and that you know
there's too much omicron around so uh we
couldn't do it um
so we're gonna have to fit it fit it in
i haven't started yet i'm excited too
it's fun it's like the the uh the
holiday special is like
i'm almost jealous of it even though i
wrote it
because people freak out so much on how
much they love the script for the
holiday special that
that i'm almost like well wait i've got
this movie here i've been working on for
two years well you love the holiday
special that i literally wrote in a very
short amount of time but you know it is
really funny and really good
your name's on both you're gonna still
get credit yeah yeah